the thing about it is as a school
resource so you have to have with love
and desire to work with you it's on your
belt today you have a you have a gun you
have what some kind of mace same things
you would have on the street yes we have
the same equipment you do the regular
officer has that's on the streets I
don't use the Taser or the sprayed it
not on my elementary kid how do you
determine what warrants handcuffs and
arrests we're not gonna be caught on
that's just a criminal violation if you
hear ok johnny was doing this and it and
then you get into it and say well that's
not a criminal violation then you might
say hey Johnny you need to just calm
down
need to do what you got to do and move
forward uh-huh nine times out of ten
it's not a criminal violation it's very
seldom very sad you see a child in
elementary school getting a criminal Joe
Mike Hawkins is one of only two black
officers and chiefs tell juses force and
it's hard to see how the discipline
policies that he describes could result
in hundreds of arrests a year I don't
want to take up too much more your time
I just want to ask you just kind of
about these numbers because these are
the school arrest numbers I'm gonna show
you these are just Southern Poverty Law
Center numbers Pinellas is third in the
state and disproportionately arresting
black children three times as many
students are arrested for disorderly
conduct in Pinellas than in Miami Miami
has three times the amount of students
that's pretty alarming is that fair to
say that does that does that sound to
you like it's working or like it's not
working
all right that's alarming listen to
their numbers yeah it's not fair to hold
me with a lot of that data well nobody's
holding officer Hawkins for all that
data we're talking we tried to ask
sorrows and they only gave us officer
office which I find curious to begin
with the question should have been yeah
to a supervisor who knows more about the
stats their fare to get to me stuff that
you really neither seem to want us to
talk to you instead I can't answer why
but each agency has their own supervisor
to watch to see what these officers are
doing and if they're not doing it that's
between them and their agency I know
what I'm doing do you think do you think
your representative of the SRO community
in this area
I feel I'm represented on myself as a
product that this neighborhood we're in
right here I grew up in here okay I went
to Melrose Elementary I'm from this
neighborhood I'm gonna continue to be in
this neighborhood and I'm gonna do all I
can but I'm not gonna be a token I'm not
here speaking as a token what would that
mean there well it what he said I was
picked because the color of my skin okay
to speak to yo
you
you